what makes you think I'm gonna make it
in life now you got to stop selling this
stuff to the sky man stop it it's
getting old
go get that job that you let go of pain
you twelve bucks an hour and part-time
get a degree stop taking these damn
risks we're not meant to do something
big with our lives simple as that hat I
want you to know this voice is never
going away this voice is always going to
be there no matter how much money you're
going to make it's always going to be
there the great thing about it is though
every morning you wake up you have a
choice on which voice to listen to but I
want you to think about a complete
different thing right now let's just say
you do nothing but you say you buy into
your fears but you say you buy into
every single thing you're worried about
but just say you don't make any
decisions to go after your dreams faster
over ten years from that 20 years from
now 30 years from now 40 years from now
let's just say your funerals around the
corner you have 50 people there hundred
people there maybe 200 people show up
these your friends family and people
that love you should be left for one
generation remembered for two
generations and forgotten after that
it's a truly the life you want to live
is that really what you want to do I
don't know if that's the life you really
want to live you see what I've noticed
is no matter what you ever do you'll
have a lot of lonely times you can lie
to your family you can lie to your
friends you can fold the world into
realizing that why you didn't win was
because of some challenge that you have
to face but there's one person you can
never like to that is a man in the
mirror you can never lie to the man in
the mirror never for the rest of your
life the man in the mirror is going to
look back at you and say you did not
choose to go after your dreams and you
have to be okay with that
now what I would like to encourage you
to do is to make the right choice I
encourage you to face your fears and
pursue your dreams
go pursue the dreams that matter the
most to you you only got one shot at
this thing here and if it works out and
it's gonna feel so good for you if it
doesn't at least you had the courage to
make that decision I hope you make the
right choice I trust you will
you